what advice would you give to a young
person like in high school
um whether there be
an artist a creative an engineer
a uh
any kind of career path or maybe just
life in general how they can live a life
they could be proud of
i think one of my big thoughts and like
especially
now having kids is that um i i don't
think we spend enough time teaching
creativity and i think creativity is a
muscle like other things and there's a
lot of emphasis on
you know learn how to play the piano and
then you can write a song or like learn
the technical stuff and then you can do
a thing but i i think it's um
like i have a friend who's like world's
greatest guitar player um
like you know amazing sort of like
producer works with other people but
he's really sort of like
you know he like engineers and records
things and like does solos but he
doesn't really like make his own music
and i was talking to him and i was like
dude you're so talented at music like
why don't you make music or whatever and
he was like because i got i'm too old i
never learned the creative muscle
and it's like you know it's embarrassing
it's like learning the creative muscle
uh takes a lot of failure
and
it also sort of
your if when you're being creative
you know you're throwing paint at a wall
and a lot of stuff will fail so like
part of it is like a tolerance for
failure and humiliation and that's um
somehow that's easier to develop when
you're young yeah yeah or be persist
through it when you're young everything
is easier to develop yes when you're
young
yes and the younger the better it could
destroy you i mean that's the shitty
thing about creativity if you know
failure could destroy you if you're not
careful but that's the risk worth taking
but also but at a young age developing a
tolerance to failure is
is good i fail all of the time like i do
stupid [ __ ] all the time
like
in public i get canceled before i i've
make all kind of mistakes but i just
like
am very resilient about making mistakes
and so then like i do a lot of things
that like other people wouldn't do and
like i think my greatest asset is my
creativity and i like i think pain like
tolerance to failure is
just
a super essential thing that should be
taught before other things brilliant
advice yeah yeah uh i wish everybody
encouraged sort of failure more
uh as opposed to kind of because we like
punish failure we're like no we're not
like when we were teaching kids we're
like no that's wrong like that's you
know uh
like
x keeps like will be like wrong like
he'll say like crazy things like x keeps
being like like bubble car bubble car
and i'm like
and
you know
i'm like what's a bubble car like but
like it doesn't like but i don't want to
be like no you're wrong i'm like
you're thinking of weird crazy [ __ ] like
i don't know what a bubble car is but
like he's creating worlds and they might
be internally consistent and through
that he might discover something
fundamental about this yeah or he'll
like rewrite songs like with words that
he prefers so like instead of baby shark
he says baby car
it's like
you